[Music]
are you Brian krzanich the CEO of Intel
yes yes I am
do you mind if I ask you a question or a
couple questions sure sure go ahead
desktop or a laptop for laptop tablet
thingy laptop laptop for sure what's the
most exciting thing happening in pcs in
the next five years yeah there's a new
memory called 3d crosspoint it's gonna
transition computers completely they're
much faster much lighter out even a
lower price so faster faster I like this
little elevator know what's the most
exciting thing coming to smartphones in
the next few years
augmented reality what's the most
ambitious thing Intel's working on oh
for sure quantum computing it's gonna
solve the world's mysteries self-driving
cars
well my 4 month old son ever learned to
drive I doubt it
really yes craziest technology idea
you've been pinched smart shoes that
could walk on water did you make it it's
not possible you come into contact with
a lot of chips what's your favorite chip
potato corn core i5 potato chips are my
favorite to eat core i7s my favorite to
use what's the number one thing you want
a robot to do for you clean up after me
I'm just the swabbing always leaving my
shoes everywhere and just be great to
have somebody walking behind oh I guess
this is you thank you thanks